former enemies now allies paying their
respect at the site of one of the single
most horrific attacks carried out in war
at the Hiroshima Peace Memorial Park a
show of unity from the G7 in response to
new dangers in a world seemingly
imperiled by new conflicts
seated for their first session a working
lunch the seven plus EU leaders heard
from the host about the mounting Global
challenges they face
the world is currently confronting
complex crises such as the pandemic the
Russian invasion of Ukraine facing these
the D7 which has fundamental values must
effectively respond to the Keys issues
of the International Community and lead
the world on this first day of the
summit the biggest news was made by a
world leader who wasn't here President
Vladimir zelenski of Ukraine but who was
widely reported to be planning to attend
in person on the last day instead of by
video link speculation that was later
denied by Kiev the G7 has issued a
lengthy statement reaffirming its
support for Ukraine and condemning the
Russian invasion it adds that a just
peace can never be realized without
Russia completely withdrawing its troops
and that this should be included in any
call for peace that's seen as a sideways
swipe against China whose peace plan has
called for a ceasefire without Russia
first giving up any of the territory it
has seized adding to the pressures on
Russia a new raft of sanctions has been
announced as well as steps to stop
Moscow getting around them
we are now focused on shutting the door
on loopholes and continue to continuing
to catch Russia off from critical
supplies we will restrict trade in
Russian diamonds Russian diamonds are
not forever this Summit being hosted by
the only country to have been the victim
of an atomic attack with the agenda
dominated by Ukraine facing its own
present-day wartime nuclear threat Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Hiroshima Japan
the Ukrainian president is expected to
travel to